chinese foreign minister wang yi has
made a surprise visit to india two years
after a deadly clash between troops from
both countries on their disputed border
wang yi met indian foreign minister s
jay shankar and national security
adviser ajit doval the visit comes in
the backdrop of a slump in bilateral
relations
a slump caused by a deadly clash between
troops of both nations in may 2020 india
accused china of breaking border
agreements and intruding into india's
claimed territory in the northern ladakh
region soldiers remain deployed along
the border and attempts to disengage
haven't yet been successful
here's a quick recap of events
a remote mountain region where
superpowers have faced off for decades
the yellow line marks the boundary
around 3 500 kilometers long between
india and china known as the line of
actual control or lac
it's not a hard border the two countries
have never agreed on where it should lie
tensions spiked in may 2020
both sides assemble troops in the area
amid reports that chinese soldiers had
set up camps on territory claimed by
india
china ordered its military to prepare
for quote worst case scenarios
a month later the two sides clashed in
the galwan valley
twenty indian soldiers were killed china
confirmed four dead a number that's been
disputed
india's prime minister responded
aggressively
beijing said it was defending its
territorial integrity accusing indian
troops of crossing the border and
provoking chinese soldiers
since the galwan incident chinese and
indian officials have met for several
rounds of talks aimed to de-escalate
tensions
in february 2021 they agreed to a
coordinated pullback
the indian military released footage of
chinese soldiers emptying out camps near
the disputed border and said it was
conducting similar actions
both sides claim the other is building
up defensive positions to fortify their
territorial claims
as mistrust continues between the
nuclear-armed rivals
and joining me now for more is jabin t
jacob he's one of india's foremost china
analysts and an associate professor at
the shiv nadar university near the
capital delhi mr jacob can i just begin
by asking you an utterly basic question
why did wang yi visit india now
well i think there are at least a couple
of reasons
one
what was reported in the news
first was that he was in town to invite
prime minister modi to the brics summit
in china
at the end of the year
but i think uh from reports that are
coming out uh
again just a few hours ago
uh
mr wangi also met with the external
affairs minister in india dr subramaniam
and they've had talks uh on the boundary
issue so at least uh
we know that these two issues uh were
discussed
uh so
given the state of uh affairs on the
line of actual control the disputed
boundary between india and china right
naturally
top of the agenda for the indians
speaking about that agenda
foreign improvement in bilateral
relations to an improvement in the
situation on that border that you were
talking about do you think wangi's visit
will help in that direction
i'm afraid i don't
believe that's likely to be the case
the chinese have given no indication
over two years that they are actually
interested in a quick solution to the
problem
we are yet to understand
what it is
that caused the chinese to engage in
these transgressions in the first place
the chinese violated decades worth of
bilateral agreements uh international
law
with their transgressions in the summer
of 2020.
so
we've had 15 rounds of military to
military talks
in the meantime and
progress as a
indian foreign minister just mentioned
has been less than desirable i mean at
the pace that is less than desirable and
i don't see that changing anytime soon
so what really is uh the the chinese
motivation here do they not want an
improvement in ties with india
uh i'm afraid the evidence points to
that direction uh the chinese are
currently at a stage where a
sense of exceptionalism a huge degree of
hyper-nationalism
drives domestic politics
and
there's a very black and white
ideological
conflict with the liberal democratic
order
that the communist party of china sees
and this conflict is is in a way good
for the existence
or continued
continuance of in power of the communist
party of china because
it
simplifies things uh for the domestic
audience it
gives the cpc the opportunity to say
look
uh the world outside uh is a bad place
we are in conflict with the world
outside and the cpc is best place to
take care of china's interests
and as long as that is a dominant
narrative at home
conflicts with the united states
with other democracies like india
will be seen as power for the course
give us a sense of the thinking in india
there have been at least 15 rounds of
military dialogue with the chinese with
no tangible result i mean troops are
still in a face-off on the border areas
does india need to accept the
possibility that china will not vacate
claimed indian territory where chinese
troops currently are
i think
india does uh at least
the smart minds within the government
system
do realize that the chinese are very
unlikely to walk away
from the areas that they've occupied
in 2020 um
but the
narrative on this side on the indian
side is that look
we've had situations like this before
uh for example in the late 1980s uh
there was a piece of territory in
arunachal pradesh that the chinese had
occupied and they took about eight years
to finally negotiate chinese withdrawal
from this area
so the indians
currently
i think labor under the impression that
this is likely to be the case also in
this instance
but uh i'm afraid that is not
uh going to be the case i mean the china
of the 1980s is not the china of today
today the chinese have a lot more
wealth economic wealth and military
might as well as national narrative
that posits uh these sort of conflicts
as essential
for china's what the chinese communist
party calls its national rejuvenation
so i think we are in a very different uh
sort of situation here
and the indian government makes a
mistake if it assumes
that it can
get the chinese to vacate only by talks
right we'll have to leave it there for
the time being but thank you so much for
joining us today jabinti jacob